hello and congratulations thank you long
time no see good to see you yeah i love
i feel like i love seeing you because
often we get to catch up about horror
movies that i love
this is one of my favorite franchises of
all time so it meant a lot to me that
they stuck the landing on this one so
thank you for that
same here
me too because i was like i was
convinced like i'm pretty sure this
movie is amazing like i do think this is
like a really good scream movie and now
so i'm happy to see some positive
reactions so like okay i was right
like taking everything in me right now
to not respond with a slew of spoilers
so
of course marley coming to you first so
judy is officially the only character to
debut in a scream sequel and actually
return for another film so after
screaming oh yeah no it's true i never
played me neither didn't get it that way
that's incredible did you think it was
gonna be one and done after screen four
honestly i had i just never crossed my
mind i you know it's been 10 years since
we did screen four
and so it was the farthest thing from my
mind i i don't think i thought about it
either way
and so when they called and and said
guess what
we're relaunching the franchise and
judy's coming back i couldn't believe it
i was thrilled very happy to hear that
myself were you shocked when you found
out that she had a son
yes i thought it was great though i mean
that was that's what's so fun with
getting to play with the passage of time
that it's been been a moment since we've
visited woodsboro um and uh i thought
that was such a fantastic way to kind of
link the new generation the new cast to
the legacy cast if you will
um
and and just the tie-in you know it's
just so funny although it's never
revealed who the father is or you know
clearly i'm a single mom that's not a
big spoiler you get you get that pretty
early on of course um
and i've also been promoted to sheriff
which is also you know i'm like okay i
like i like where things are going to
judy i got a whole lot of questions
about that right now that i'm not
allowed to ask
sticking with the uh the mother-son
relationship so you two sell it
extremely well and with very limited
screen time and when something like that
happens it's like even though i got
enough i can't help but to want to know
every single detail about it so just for
the two of you for your own heads did
you have to develop any additional
backstory that we don't see on screen in
order to create a foundation for their
relationship
well we took it very seriously we
actually like lived in a house together
for a week and
hopefully no
no
we i mean we did we talked about
i think the most obvious dynamic that we
established was that they're um
you know wes is a bit of a mama's boy
and i'm this kind of overprotective
obviously i'm
a cop i'm overprotective overbearing
um
mother bear
uh you know and i'm a single mom so i
think i even put more emphasis on on
that role of mothering
um
and so he has to kind of find his way
through that dynamic a little bit
so dylan for you with with west as his
concerns about you know things like
putting tape over your camera on your
phone and having a taser does all of
that stem from the fact that his mother
is a cop and just knowing what she went
through in the past absolutely and i
think like he is a mama's boy like she
said and he really loves and respects
his mom so he takes her very seriously
and i think he's like
he's trying to get his friends to take
it seriously too because i think he's
just a really deeply caring person and
he cares about his friends
um but he doesn't want to embarrass
himself either so he's trying to walk
this fine line but he's an easy punching
bag he's like an easy target for the
friends but
a little bit
are
there any i guess kind of fun hicks
family easter eggs in the house set that
you really hope people notice heck yeah
but we're not going to say what they are
i almost said it right out i was like
i can't wait to like own the movie so i
could go frame by frame
i think i caught a few things but i feel
like there's a lot more hidden back
there that i don't know
this is nothing that's hidden and it's
not a spoiler but
it's not nobody's i'm not getting into
trouble um there's a moment where i'm
like just going through like food items
or something and i
take out i'm like saying to myself i'm
like yeah you know grab this and this i
pull out soy sauce and i just say this
and i had to like do it in adr and it's
like funny that i'm like naming off
things but could it name soy sauce
does it anyway it doesn't matter wes
doesn't know what soy sauce is
apparently that's like it's anyway he's
a shell he's he's a sheltered lab
exactly didn't even notice so joe
there's something else in the fridge
there's something else in the fridge we
won't see what it is oh i know what that
is and i very much appreciated that
there's a sweet treat that yeah that
fans will appreciate
and confirm so for both of you now i
know you've both done a good deal of
horror over the years so is there
anything that was done on this new
screen movie even with all your
experience that you know kind of made
you go
i can't believe doing this on set makes
it look like this on screen like
something horror movie magic wise
oh what a good question
mean i feel like it has to do with like
gags like you know if there's a if
there's a gag of someone getting stabbed
and it's sort of
it's it can happen so quick on screen
and in the screen movies it does
normally happen really quick and really
brutally um but it's the process that it
takes into like
if someone's getting stabbed and like
the blood that has to pump out and the
mess that it makes and how long the
prosthetic takes to put on like all
those things it's like it's resetting
right yeah yeah exactly and i feel like
i haven't even i've done horror i
haven't i don't think i've been involved
in something where it's like a slasher
you know so
um
yeah i mean it's just like the care and
effort that's put into just hours and
hours but on screen it's just a quick
brutal moment and that's the movie magic
you know that's what it is
how about for you marley
i have to agree with with dylan i think
it's it's um
for a quick
like jump scare beat
it could be hours of preparation and
you know detailed
meetings and
with with the props department and the
stunt coordinator and just to get that
one spine tingling
chilling moment um which is pretty cool
i mean that it is music movie magic that
you can create that you can you can
create that in an audience
well worth all the time and care that
goes into it this is really random but
i've gotten very obsessed about asking
about rap gifts just because they're all
so film specific so what was the rap
gift on this movie
i've there were more rap gifts on this
than i've ever seen like every single
person made a different shirt or hoodie
of some kind
with some sort of inside joke from the
thing like i have like a a woodsboro
crew neck and like uh you know a thing
that says five cream on it and like
things that have inside like there's so
many i'm like in my closet like a mound
of shirts and hoodies from uh from
various
cast and crew which is the sign of a
really
amazing experience people there was so
much love going around on this
particular
set um everyone got along swimmingly and
yeah it's just a
great group seriously yeah
that quality radiates off the screen and
it's something i really appreciated
about the film they're going to kick me
out i have so many more questions i want
to ask you to i wish we could talk more
yeah
for another time
but again congratulations and thank you
for talking to me today yeah thank you
appreciate it
you